I'm supposed to blue play as a- I live noise game, noise filter.
First thing first, I need to get close. I can't accept.
What was your name again?
It seems like your ears, oh dear, are a little bit cloned up, Mr. Wiefling.
Let me just inspect this ear. Oh dear, that's good.
Mr. Wiefling always really cloned up here.
Oh dear, and now let me check your other ear, Mr. Wiefling.
Do I sound muffled in this ear as well? Oh dear, there's something obstructing your ear canal.
Oh, that's my, I mustn't sound so muffled.
Oh wow, nurse, re-in, nurse, I see. Just came to our ear cleaning suite with our assistants, the snowberries, thank you.
Alright, okay, I think I know what to start with.
I feel like, oh sorry, Mr. Wiefling, you're not a little feeling your client at my ear cleaning facility.
Okay, first thing first, we're going to do is listen to the wax that's stuck in your ears.
It has an anti-fat-packed properties because ear wax is a pretty fatty substance, so just going to spray over your ear.
Don't worry, it's wet, so it's not, it's cool.
Okay, then for this ear, Mr. Wiefling, do you feel like that did anything for you?
Or do you need a bit more, I think you need a bit more ear, oh dear.
Okay, now that the solution on your ear, I'm just going to dry every single ear canal.
Yes, your actual ear and the earwax, because I don't want you dripping my Mr. Wiefling, that's not very appropriate for this thing.
Okay, dear, dear, but I still sound a little old.
You are probably the worst case I've seen in a while.
Are you listening with headphones on?
Is your day job maybe working at a PC?
Let me see, not so good.
What?
Not so good at all.
This sound has just gotten off of my focusing.
What the?
Right, I've taken off the fucking noise gate, back to the roleplay boys.
Oh dear.
Yes, I think you may be wearing a lot of headphones, because this is the most clogged ears I've seen in a very long time.
Okay, your ear is now clean at all.
I'm going to do this check here and canal and see if I can remove any debris at this point.
But that is very tightly packed in.
How do you think we should get rid of a good maybe ears?
A Japanese ear cleaning tool in combination.
This is quite the challenge today, Mr. Wiefling.
Just checking.
Definitely a solid mass over your ear.
I assume this ear is going to be the exact same story.
Oh yeah.
I think what we'll have to do is do this day by day.
Just take out a little bit.
But the procedure shouldn't take more than 12 minutes, okay?
So don't worry, I won't steal too much of your time.
I'm sure you're a very busy man, Mr. Wiefling.
So I'm just going to try and dislodge some of the ear.
It should be hard again.
Let's see if this tool will offer a bit more texture here.
Here.
I'm just removing what I can very delicately because I don't want to hurt your ear.
So you'll need to tell me in the hearts, okay?
Because we don't want no problem.
This isn't easy.
Okay.
We're getting somewhere, Mr. Wiefling.
Getting somewhere.
Oh, you work in an ink factory, Mr. Wiefling.
That's a curious job.
What do you do when you work in the ink factory?
Definitely get some work done.
That was painful, wasn't it?
Your ears are already feeling some relief.
I've actually not even cleaned one ear out fully yet.
So I've still muffled so you guys are jumping ahead of the roleplay.
Hold on.
It's gone in your ear.
I've put it in a creepy patch, isn't it?
You feel the ink machine?
Oh, you feel the ink machine?
Yeah, I guess it probably runs on some sort of liquid that is high in vitamin D extract.
I don't know if you guys will forget.
Yeah.
Oh, you have Associates, Mr. Wiefling, that work in the production of the ink as well.
It sounds like a very efficient factory.
That's quite a good job.
My job is to have one that I close pretty quickly.
Well, of course I have my lovelaces.
You did my appointment with the license.
Wow.
I've almost got it actually. Hold on.
I've literally almost got this ear clean.
You're very close.
Very close to getting this ear dislodged.
Okay.
But we have to be super gentle because I don't want to hurt you.
Oh, I think it's coming.
Do you hear me now, Mr. Wiefling?
Did that work?
I think it did.
Hold on. Let me just spray down your ear again.
Just so...
Wow.
That's perfect.
There we go. Let me just quickly rub down your ear.
And then we will tackle the other one here.
Oh, that's great.
I'm glad you feel relief in this ear.
I'm just going to make sure to brush away all the debris because it might sound like your hearing is completely back.
But your baseline, Mr. Wiefling, was very low.
So I'm just going to make sure to brush away any nastiness that may have been left over, okay?
Because we don't want any nastiness.
I just had a cat here in your ear.
Do you have a cat, Mr. Wiefling?
Do you have two cats?
What are their names?
Yeah.
Wow. Okay, that's probably all the dust.
And then we're super careful.
Just gently gently rub that.
Okay, this ear, I think, I'm just going to take another look into it.
But it looks pretty clear to me.
I will come back to it just in case.
But unfortunately, this ear is still very much full and muffled.
Let's see what we can do over here.
Oh, oh, you don't have a cat, Mr. Wiefling, but you had named them after the Fieler Girls.
Or unfortunately, I'm not familiar with the Fieler Girls.
Would you like to describe in great detail who or what the Fieler Girls are?
Whilst I clean up this very troublesome ear of yours.
Just, again, just tell me if there's any pain and I'll stop.
Because I definitely don't want to hurt you.
Oh, that's bad.
My cat's name is Wandalabism.
Interesting name for a cat.
I wonder, did you come up with that by yourself?
Okay, there's no pain. Good.
I'm just trying to pick apart the large nerves and then I can actually clean your ears.
Oh my goodness, this is, you're just tasting me.
This is the most difficult case I've had in very long time.
It keeps the ear clean, yeah.
So, Mr. Wiefling, you're having a tingly experience.
Oh, that's good.
My ear tingles can be quite relaxing.
Maybe you can give me a pack for some tickles, we are.
One of them has warm and colored hair. It's totally not safe.
Okay, one interesting girl group this sense.
There's a very cute little sister type and also our mummy is pretty hot.
Oh, this sense of a very interesting girl.
And it sounds like the guava base is covered.
Mr. Wiefling, did I hear you correctly?
You asked me to smell your ears.
Well, this one's blocked, so I can't really tell you, but...
Interesting.
Well, the good news is you don't have any signs of infection because you can smell it.
And I didn't smell any signs of infection.
Just need to get this.
And almost there, I really am.
I swear you have some very difficult ears.
Hold on, let me get on you too, because I don't think this is working as well as I had hoped.
Wow.
Oh, that was quite loud over here.
We're getting there. We're almost there, Mr. Wiefling.
And then you can finally hear me and my family.
Okay.
I think I got it.
Hello, Mr. Wiefling. How can you hear me?
That's going well.
I just need to make sure there's no remnants, because there might be some left over.
Gunk is always, but I sound a little clearer.
Oh, there we go.
Clear, clear.
I think everything sounds clear now. That's good, Mr. Wiefling and glad.
Okay, just a quick brush up to make sure that you don't have any more dust or dirt in them.
You should begin to go.
Oh, I forgot to spray you a little bit, sir. You don't mind if I spray on you, right?
There we go. Just tap the over here so that it's not bled on.
And then give you a little brush brush.
There we go.
Wow.
I think so, and while I'm here, never hand in a Scottish Dome.
Okay, I think we did it. Your ears, Mr. Wiefling, appear clean.
Very clean.
Okay, goodbye.
Thank you so much for your attendance at the care clinic.
I hope you had a good day and that all of your issues have been resolved now.
For the matter of payment, you have to give me one kiss.
Mr. Wiefling, I said you have to give me one kiss.
You need to kiss me. Kiss me.
Good morning. Good evening. Good afternoon, my little Wiefling.
Did you like my cringey roleplay? I thought I did a pretty good job.
I have a confession reference. I accidentally don't want someone yesterday.
And I'm 99% sure.
Oh, pardon me.
I think it was dimsul. I don't want to hold you yesterday.
Your dad is going to be even more confused when you claim you have five dollars. That makes him a granddad.
It was good. Yeah, you liked it. Did you like it? You were all muffled.
I wonder if I have a roleplay like that coming out soon.
I said thank you for $2,000. Can I pay again?
Being called Mr. Wiefling makes me feel like a big shot. I also must have lost the address.
And then let me just check the...
Oh, of course it doesn't work, so I need to go into my own life struggle.
What? That's me.
Wait, why is it not displaying?
And then thank you very much, Brightgo for the day and gifted memberships. We appreciate you.
And congrats to all the Wieflings that caught one. Be nice and say thank you.
John07, thank you for becoming a member.
Vanished, thank you for becoming a member.
Rockstar, the Avril Fluff, Jupro, Mamosa.
Mamosa became a member. When did you do that?
Type N and Tiki, thank you also for becoming a member. What the heck?
I'm so sorry, you little Wieflings, I'm exhausted.
I'm okay, but I have nine toenails now.
Oh, floss, thank you for becoming a member. I appreciate you.
I don't remember when Mamosa became a member.
Thank you so much for becoming a member.
I apologize about any yawns or complaints of pain.
I'm online pain killers, but I'm surviving. It's not a big deal.
Am I allowed to say the story or pour one out from all me the toenail?
You were sacrificed in the name of pretty feet and you went out the way mommy wanted ya to be sexy.
I definitely need a big sleep. I did get one, but I think it's one of those.
I need rest and recovery sleep.
The pointy tool was a bit surprising. I definitely felt that going into my tool.
I felt that basically once they tested if I could feel anything, once it came through and I was like, no, I don't feel anything.
They got to work and they said, lie back, you don't want to see this.
It's currently covered up right now and I need to change it in less than 48 hours so I get to see what the damage is.
They've given me a medical bag of gauze and everything to take away, but I know how to clean and change bandages.
It's not a big deal.
Whatever you want to call it.
Strongly the one K.A smart video was amazing. You liked it.
I'll need a check actually.
So YouTube put limited ads on my let me hold it video and then I was like, I'll find that's fair because of the content.
But on a whim, I applied to get limited ad taken off it and they gave me it.
So I've just lost like 40,000 views worth of like generated ad revenue that would have paid for that artwork.
Thank you for becoming a member. I appreciate it.
Yes, chat is so great.
Abba tea, abba dye, rip strongy feet fans, well she be and Emma work again.
So you don't have to worry.
But I apologize for yours. I am a very sleepy baby.
But we are going also. Thank you.
I say for the rage goodness gravy. I can't.
Sorry. I've only takes off.
I'll just pop you down in my lap.
I've literally sweat up and only takes off.
It's so damp in here.
I was trying to do the roleplay right.
I can't take it. I can't get it.
It's not okay. This is so wet.
What?
Would you never do a ridicule again?
Oh, I have no intention of doing one.
Like I was going to do for a month on a phone.
I was going to do like these pictures and be like this says for feet people only.
Yeah, feet people ain't getting fit.
Nothing. Nothing.
My hair looks like watermelon candy.
Heck yeah, it does.
A story called ACMA.
I've said this before but they were called the twins in development.
Or I dubbed them the twins in development.
Why you ask? Because I don't know.
It just came naturally to me to call them the twins.
They are called.
How much for the glove?
It's so sweaty and it's terrible.
My hand can breathe now.
But I also have this box of like weird bailet slime.
I don't, let me get it.
I was going to bet it.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Even if I had to ASMR stream.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
I bought this weird box of slime.
Hold on.
What?
It's so good.
It sounds really bad but I just have all my figurines
wink wink on display in this room.
Okay, Bono has got that light plastic on it.
I'm going to turn down the volume.
I'm going to cut the slime.
The black.
Okay, I think I can fit the volume up again.
What the fuck is this?
So I was supposed to put this on your ear.
Did you hear what this is?
Oh, it's sticky.
This isn't slime all.
I was supposed to put it on your ear.
Just even make a noise.
Do you hear that?
It sounds like nothing is shit.
I'm going to scum ass.
Mommy, I always thought that you are that person
to interview the girls.
Did that sexual harassment?
Wait, so does this slime not do anything?
Wait, hold on.
I'm taking my headset off so I can hear it.
Oh my god, it's so sticky.
Why?
It's going everywhere as well.
I'm going to have to clean all of this.
The future person must not stream live.
Click, no clickbait.
Okay, I'm just going to use my finger.
Hold on.
It's on me now.
What does that sound like?
Do you hear it just sounds like
slightly sticky sounds?
I paid like all $12 for this.
I don't know, maybe it's one of those tingle sounds
that are better for like layering with other ASMR.
Like this.
How's Gimli?
Actually, Fiko snuck in at the room.
He's not supposed to be in here.
And this freaking tail was hanging off the window
literally like three minutes before moving upstream.
And I was like, get it out.
Because they're not supposed to be in this room at all.
Because I've got far too much equipment in here.
Yeah, it's kind of low.
Wow, it just kind of sounds like plastic.
Oh, it's supposed to kill my hands.
It's supposed to kill my nose.
Oh, we're done.
I'll just put it on this used napkin from a week ago.
I'll record with it.
Maybe I can use it as a layer to take an experience.
$12.
Let me hold it.
Let me.
Oh, yucky.
Oh, there's like a residue on my hands now.
Oh.
I actually...
Sorry, I'm trying to get the residue on my hands.
How much for that napkin?
It's not real. It's not my own.
It's like both my pinkies are all black.
Okay.
I'll put it on for more e-paste.
You don't need to go on a page for more.
Right, where's my...
Oh, here it is.
My god.
It's my little...
I don't know if you guys like tapping like that.
Just testing your hearing now after your little...
Is today the watch along?
It should be unless I completely messed up.
I actually had to leave.
I was putting up my streams for the week.
And then I was like, oh, should I slow?
I have to go for my doctor's appointment.
So I just disappeared.
And all I've got up is...
Wait, I've up at the...
Yeah.
It's a Transformers...
Autobots...
Fallout.
It's like both lane.
Yeah.
We're watching Transformers.
The first one with Sam Webuki.
So congrats if your name is...
It's scheduled for 4.15pm.
That is probably why it's at the horrifically wrong time.
It should be 6.15am.
Lol.
Okay, I've just updated the member watch along.
Does it look right on your hand now?
Smile.
I think I've put the wrong time for the Minish Cap as well.
Actually, hold on.
Yeah, I've put 4pm instead of 4am for the Minish Cap.
Don't mess.
I'm not very brave, am I?
I can't wait to show you guys.
Actually, I'll show you right now.
Oh, no, I can't.
Because I don't think I have a...
Transformers...
AC...
What the fuck, AC?
Call her again, Ben.
What?
Is AC's Twitter down?
AC, what did you do?
Your account is logged after a careful review.
With the damage your account broke, some brails on Twitter.
Your account is read only movement tunes.
You can't pause, read post-release content.
Most accounts regain fill access in a week, but it could take longer.
AC, what did she do?
What the fuck did she do, yeah?
You know what it feels like?
What?
I'm sorry if you heard that.
I wanted to shut my thumbnails off.
Ready?
She became too powerful, actually.
She told the pot to keep itself safe in Minecraft.
Okay.
Oh, sorry, I'm rubbing my eyes.
Mommy's tired and trying her best to transform her stream.
It's gonna be so close.
I'm, like, warning you all that.
Sorry.
Oh, my eyes are...
Actually, no.
Sorry.
What?
Gosh.
Like, these pretty eyes don't come without a downside.
Okay.
Image.
Refling.
Uh, Elden Rain.
What do you guys think about my thumbnail?
Let's open it.
What do you think?
It is pretty good.
Like, there's two good reflings and then one bad invader refling.
And then I have a pot on my head because of that guy that always kills that girl with a pot on his head.
And then, for the next thumbnail, you guys are defending me.
Look, invaders go in first.
And then the two good reflings are in front of me.
And then I'm buying just you up in my head, all like...
See, you guys are keeping me safe.
It's great.
I'm glad you think so.
Wow.
Let me solo her.
Yes, that's the name. Let me solo her.
So, I'm going to hopefully have my heart rate shock collar set up.
So, every time I cause us to lose of height, you guys get to shock me and you get to see when.
But I don't know how to set up the when thing.
I don't know if I could collectively get you all to make to the anticipation and whatever reflings is.
You know, shock first, that shock.
Am I leaking again?
Leaking what?
We can all solo Strony.
I just get in the lane.
Get that premium pass.
Then I put it up a PC.
Because I need me to get that Fortnay Baobass.
Falk Niel Lar. Yes, I thought it through.
Are you going to set up a group password?
Of course.
I think the password is four layers long.
So, maybe we'll put like...
Fair for green and French.
And then Fortnay Baobass.
Do you start immediately for the watch along or for...
Elden, right?
There's a 15 minute break after this ASMR because I need to swap my microphones around.
Because I'm using my 3Dio right now.
But I use an SMB7.
And that's when you can hear...
Well, actually the 3Dio shows you how echoey the room is.
Oh, I forgot to make a T.
Trat.
Did you see Emmy Shulker's self on the watch along?
I did not.
I've kind of said this before.
The only thing I...
Not dislike.
Well, I guess it's dislike.
I don't have time to watch the streams.
I have time to watch Mersi.
Because what happens normally after a stream?
I'll get a T and record what I need to record.
And all that.
And plan what I need to do.
I've recorded 3 ASMR collabs.
So, I'm editing Mamosa's first.
Because it's super simple and easy.
There's not even like 4 minutes of dialogue.
But I made the biggest mistake of trying to record during the freaking day.
It was like car after car after car.
But I caught some of Mersi's karaoke.
And oh my god, I want to do her karaoke.
You know the guy that goes,
I want to do her karaoke right now.
Because of Mersi.
She was just so fun.
And she was singing the most adorable songs.
And it was so precious.
So, I'm really excited to...
She made some fun noises.
And I think you will too.
And me and Freak, she probably liked that.
But I'm going to see if I can do karaoke next week.
I can't remember what.
So next week is the last of June.
And I wanted to wrap up RuneScape.
And I wanted to finish Elden Ring.
But the problem is they're both insurances.
The voice is breaking.
Shit.
And I was like, I want to go back on Skyrim.
Because I fixed the achievements on Skyrim.
So we can actually play through the game properly.
And not get distracted.
But I'm so unprofessional.
There's genuinely...
I'm not being funny if there's a vampire out there.
Going to me a favor and infect me.
Because if I didn't need to sleep, the content that would be cooked.
She loved it.
And after.
She was really cute.
I'm glad.
But yeah, if I didn't need to sleep,
I could do all these things all at once.
I've got three ASMR collabs I need to edit.
Which I think I can probably do today.
And then soon.
And just be like, I'm going to upload it soon dm.
I want to upload my second 2k audio.
And then I want to message.
And then I want to upload mimosa.
And then two more 1000 subscriber thank yous.
And then the next collab partner.
Which I don't think I've said who it is.
But I made the plots super easy for the girls.
I didn't want to overwhelm them.
I'm so sorry my voice is breaking.
If you can hear that.
But I need my throat to recover.
See, next week we're writing some scripts together.
And you guys are actually going to help me write the missing script for this month.
So you get to tell me what you want to hear.
Favourite companion in Skyrim.
Mjöl.
Mjöl or Serena.
That's nice, I like Serena.
If you were a vampire, I would let you have my blood.
You'd let me feed on you.
I just don't sleep in the middle of some squid ink spaghetti.
So I can make squid slime spaghetti.
But you guys can make squid ink spaghetti.
See, I slime and you ink.
You jack ink.
I gel slime.
But yeah, I hope to have more ASMR up today.
I've made myself a little mini promise.
Which is where I will instigate 10 ASMR collabs per month.
Which means if all goes well, I will have completed my goal of 100 feature per collabs.
Before a year is finished.
So I have 6 collabs instigated with other features.
I'm going to put my big girl pants on and reach out to a few other people.
But I'm limiting it to 10 only.
I don't want to ask any more than 10.
So I need to finish this current batch before I can ask the 11th person.
That makes sense.
That's a lot of collabs.
Ain't no picture here or can't watch that.
I'm so sorry.
I accidentally just put your cleaner up my nose.
That feel awful.
I've been sorry.
When on the hook, I get really animated.
I was thrown around the ear clinic.
And it went open.
You're definitely ambitious.
Because I was always weaving it around like a wandering pot.
Like a wandering garden.
It was true.
Sorry, I'm crying right now.
I'm laughter.
I'm crying.
I don't want to release more.
I'm sorry.
I'm just supposed to be relaxed.
I'm fucking losing it mate.
I'm wiping away my tears.
It's not that funny.
I just need to calm down.
I'm so sorry.
I'm high on painkillers.
It wasn't that funny.
I'm just sick of it.
I'm done.
I have so much tears coming out of my eyes.
I'm wiping away my wee tears.
I'm sorry.
I forgot.
I'm back to his mind.
I'm sorry.
Are you flaying?
You made me cry.
I'm embarrassed.
I should get that turned into a clip.
Why not?
Streamer loses it after sticking at your cleaner up thing.
I'm okay.
Breathe in.
Breathe out.
ASMR.
Shhh.
Relax.
I wish I had this picture that I found yesterday.
It was really funny.
I wish I could show you it.
But I turned my phone off after TikTok opened itself up.
That other stream.
Okay, sorry.
Relax.
The moon that waits today was a filming yesterday.
Okay, there we go.
Shhh.
It's like when you did debut
and put that you wanted to list
and made one too.
Shhh.
No, seriously.
How did you manage to get on?
I was waving about
when I talk
I like wave my hands around
and like basically
I just perfectly leaned
to go in.
Shhh.
Okay.
Now excuse me.
Well, now we know where your funny button is.
Oh, this noise.
Actually,
it's disgusting.
Humor is far humor.
There's like this trend
where you golf
to try and cover up your far.
Your far?
But you like purposely golf
way before the far.
Before the far.
Then your far.
Shhh.
Sorry.
I've not been funny.
And when you guys sent an audio
of your farted marshmallow,
I think I would absolutely lose it.
Shhh.
ASMR ASMR.
My professional ASMR.
By the way,
this is my livelihood.
It's exactly what we did.
Another brief
It's that request. Stop. If someone does sit and chat, check your washable because I'm
in a very giggly mid right now, it must be the painkillers or what. I'm just on a high
dose, it's not even like anything serious. Alright, a volunteer's tribute. It's like,
so the trend is you like cough to cover up your fart and then your fart, so it's delayed,
so everyone notices your fart. ASMR strongly makes, I should probably change the title of
this stream and just call it ASMR by field violently. Okay, brush your nose with your
ear cleaner. Brush my nose with your ear cleaner. Have you heard about a joke at first?
My favorite one is like, whenever you fart, just say, oh do you smell popcorn? So everyone takes
the big one. So everyone goes, and for some reason Yoda is in my head whenever I say that.
Because there's a shot of Yoda leaning backwards in Star Wars, and it looks like he's taken a big
old sniff.
And this is so, have you seen the one where the dead drops a plate on the floor and they
take like, this is bad. No.
You can't take this.
I can't. I'm so sorry.
No, I haven't seen it.
I'm fucking gone. I can't even handle farting in my head.
I'm so sorry. I'm like crying and spitting everywhere right now.
This is an ASMR. I don't even know why I bothered labeling these days. You know what,
I'm just going to start labeling ASMR streams, not ASMR.
I have so many to you. I've never cried or laughed for so long. Actually, I think this is the first
time I've cried and laughed, and thank you refunds. I really needed this one.
Oh my god. ASMR is more like ASMR fart.
Strawny hypnotizes to peel your finger. I'm so sorry. Okay, whisper, whisper, whisper.
It was just the way that message was typed out. Oh, did you see the one where the guy
smashed a plate in shams? That is so specific. Wipe, smash a plate. I'm going to cough, sorry.
Oh, there's stuff stuck in my throat. That stuff in her throat, literally me.
Sorry, I'm going to need to actually cough.
Oh, gone. Oh, okay. I'm so sorry. Right. Actually, ASMR.
Only one more hour of the giggles to go.
Oh, actually, I'm going to redirect into Sheebie, and then I go offline for 15 minutes,
and then we watch Transformers. It is a membership watch alone, but free access stream though, smile.
We heard it. I heard what? A fortuse. Don't be like this. She tried to cover it with a cough.
I've actually heard my voice from laughing so hard, as well as whispering. So now...
It's okay, good.
Remember the Yoda crying video where he gets slapped, yeah? She beats five hours.
Wait, I can't redirect into anyone, I feel her. Oh my god. My unit is broken in AC's offline.
I can't stream because I need to do, well, I need to do the watch alone, and I need to rest and come for a nap.
You'll have to get to the next one. Well, you got to hear my laughing fit, so...
I downloaded Transformers 2007 with Sam Webwiki, and Megan Fox, and Bumblebee.
Feel her unity over a glittering portrait here.
Will the watch alone have a tape stamp? Oh, I'll raise you one even better than a tape stamp.
It will also be on screen, but blurred, so you know that we're together at the same section.
So please don't worry about not being able to be at the same time as me. You're gonna know if you're at the same time as me.
It's too firm.
I'm cleaning your ear right now with a little sponge, although maybe I should clean it with my dog.
Is that better? I think so. Yeah, that looks better.
Okay, just dry you off a little bit.
Please show the girls how to do that. Okay, yes.
I'm going for a nap. I can go to our classic bubbles.
Thank you, Stronny. You're awesome. No, you're awesome. Refling.
Wow.
I want to be hypnotized soon, too.
I've basically, sorry, my voice is really struggling.
I basically am going to achieve, I'm going to focus on RuneScape, and I'm going to focus on Elden Ring.
And then in July, I'm doing all my secret side missions, which is like the free audio uploads and all that.
Stronny, what's the spray you're using earlier? It's my slime.
I made homemade slime and put it in a bowl to spray on YouTube and stream to hear it.
I have to add water so it's extra slimy.
But yeah, a little bowl of my slime. Let's go with my pheromones in it.
But yes, RuneScape and Elden Ring are my objective, mission objective.
I'm so sorry. I'm going to drink, I'm going to take a drink of water.
Have you fucked with my voice? Wow, it's this fucked.
Remember kids, don't do ASMR. Girls, you end up like me.
Oh my god, it's something like an old woman from Skyrim.
Talking to an old woman trying to do your good deed for the day?
Yes, or I sound like the thing from Conker's Bad Fur Day at the start or something.
It's Gryllococaine. Oh, that's a Gryllococaine.
Old women, old women are female.
Here to do your good deed for the day, Sunny.
Oh dear, your ears look so cold. What do I call you, sweetheart?
Oh, yes, your ears are too cold. Be out here.
Let me warm them up for you.
See, Sunny, that feels better.
You should rest your voice.
I should, but I'm going to have a honey tea and then I will watch Transformers.
Call me Riefling, please. Riefling.
Okay, have a fluffy make-up part.
You sound like female Voldemort.
What does Voldemort even say?
Harry! Harry, I can touch you.
It's over for you.
Yeah.
Gentle girlfriend. Oh, she's English, isn't she?
Who does gentle English is for school?
Hello, I'm English. I'm gentle girlfriend.
And I have a naturally soothing voice.
Unfortunately, this is definitely not where she's located in England,
so I do apologise if I'm insulting you.
Would you guys still love me if I was English, to be honest?
And there's actually only one right answer to that question.
And the answer is no.
You're supposed to say you only love me Scottish.
Imagine. Imagine, yeah? If I was English.
Landusie.
Echelon. Oh my god, would you get tingles if I gave you ASMR as a child?
You're not really going to get tingles, are you?
You're such a naughty boy, Riefling.
You're so strange like that, honestly.
Can I get a Chauvin gen 2 of that big group?
Riefling, so what's wrong with you?
All you do is ink around the place.
I'm starting to think you like when I go and I chewed Rieflings.
Could be French, Stedeon.
Bonjour, Rieflings.
Salut, ça va?
Bonne nuit.
Bonne avenue.
Bon veilleux.
Hello.
Ma préférée, Riefling.
ASMR, Struits, en français.
Oh mon Riefling.
J'ai besoin de ça.
Ah, thank you, tiny spinny, for the tip.
Ah, enjoy my stream.
This sounds very wrong.
Didn't he ask for German next?
I can't need any German.
Sad to say, I'll be gone for the watch-along at work,
but I'll have to catch up to the watch-along before I'd enjoy it.
I will.
Your chaos comes so naturally, it's hard to follow,
but so easy to enjoy.
Oh, I'm glad you like my chaos.
It makes me feel very appreciated.
Here, let me show you my appreciation for you.
French, Ronnie, can you hurt ya?
For some reason, whenever I speak French, my voice goes lighter.
Bonjour, de l'aimant.
Salut, je suis Stronica Delce.
Salut, ça va?
Bien, ouais, ouais, bien.
I don't know why I go late when I speak French.
Tu peux soire ASMR?
Pour deux, Monsieur, pour deux, deux minutes, ASMR, deux.
Yeah, I don't know why, it just naturally goes fucking later.
When I'm all the way down here, I'm a default.
It's charming.
Well, glad you think so.
Well, I can't, I don't have a German accent.
I don't think I have a Dutch accent.
Hallo.
Ich bin Stronica Delce.
No, I don't have a Dutch accent, really.
Ich spelen.
Ich spelen?
Nee, ich stremen auf YouTube mit ASMR.
Wie bin ich?
Ich bin Stronica Delce.
Ich hau von Jau.
Ich hau von Juli.
Yeah, I don't have a Dutch accent.
Sorry, I need more water.
How long did it take you to learn French?
I actually don't know French.
It's just, I repeat words and throw sentences together, but I actually don't know.
American Stronica would be hilarious.
Well, yes, you might just get ash from Overwatch, because it's ash here.
Is there a chance that videos that get taken down be uploaded to Patreon?
Timothy Shaw, thank you for the tip.
I can upload videos, but I can upload audios.
I'm using my current Patreon as an audio sound bank.
I upload the stuff I put on YouTube up on it as well.
I actually, so I, you know what?
I can make you a deal.
Do you want to know how good I am at dancing the rules of YouTube?
Not one stream or one video on my YouTube channel is limited ads.
You have to admit, this cut off fish is bloody cunning.
Can you speak with a lisp for Dutch?
Have to speak with a lisp for Dutch.
For native ones.
Dutch mincing?
How about Canadian accent?
I am going to be so stereotypical when I say this.
I do not hear much of a difference between Americans and Canadians.
I'm so sorry.
I can't hear an accent differentiation.
Yeah, I know.
Put me in the bin.
Spanish?
I have no experience with Spanish, unfortunately.
I know sombre voicelines.
Augusta, my pantyhorn.
Merda.
How about a Kiwi accent?
Real, it's the same.
Shit, I'm so sorry.
Just don't tell me it's the same.
There really isn't a certain word.
It sounds like Kiwi accent.
I used to be able to do an Australian news anchor.
And here we are reporting.
No, well my voice is too fried for it.
But Kiwi accent is too hard.
The only Kiwi I can do is a Coca-Cola glass.
A Pepsi bottle.
I don't give a Dean.
It's the only Kiwi I can do.
Lol, I actually think that Canadians just sound like Midwesterners
with a slight French twinge.
Like, I know it's controversial,
but it kind of just feels like the same side of a coin.
And everyone's been like, no, that side's head and that side tails.
Like, as an outsider, like as a European.
Um, with like, obviously,
with European's geography, everyone is so close by,
like Belgium, Netherlands, France, Germany, Poland, right over there.
Like, those are accent differentiations.
If you think of how massive the land mass of America and Canada is,
and you're telling me that that's such an immense difference,
I'm sorry, but call me 20 because I didn't hear it.
Wonder if Dutch English accent sounds cute to Anglophones' Dutch accent sounds
to Northern Germans, because we find them adorable.
Okay guys, I'm gonna just start seeing random Dutch stuff
I can remember off the top of my head.
Tell me if you think it's cute or not, so we can answer this guy's question.
Hello, how are you? I'm Strony Cattles.
I live in Australia, I have hunger.
I don't have a Dutch family.
To be honest, I teach Dutch on the Xbox.
There's one reason why I don't have it so much,
because I've been friends with Freemasonians,
but I have no friends anymore.
That's the best German for you.
I don't speak English, so I eat stropwafel, where my...
Big Vast!
You just throw random English words at the end of them.
Anything you say is cute, but you're just trying to get me a bullet, aren't you?
I give up, I give up.
You're cute, no matter what.
I'm not smart, but...
Ikal van jou!
I just said, I'm not very smart, but I love you!
Ik ben nietslim mar ikal van jou!
To say I love you in Dutch, you say...
Ikal van jou!
And to say I love you all in Dutch, like if I was talking to all the reflinks, you say...
Ikal van jullie!
And then in German, ich liebe dich.
Wah!
Did I just say something? I think I just said, ich liebe Schwanze.
Oops.
To say I love you in French, you say...
Je t'aime, je t'aime ma chérie!
And to say I love you in Scotland, you say...
What do you say?
I would probably be derogatory.
Okay, oops.
I said it wrong.
You just need to say this.
Ich liebe dich.
And then to say I love you in Spanish, te amo.
Te amo mi amor!
Y mi amores!
In Polish, I don't know how to say it in Polish.
Te amo.
Oh, Italian's Te amo.
Upsiens Te amo!
Nope, you didn't read it after.
Girl knows how to speak German.
Nein, is das Gras rot?
Nein, das Gras ist klein!
That's the only German I know.
And also you just call the person a Sicker.
Yeah, basically.
You pronounce it...
Desh, desh, ish, liebe desh.
Yay, thanks for the Spanish.
And Turkish, in Turkish...
Sem, ni, seviyorum.
Sem ni seviyorum, sem, sem ni seviyorum.
A cut-fish of many talents.
No, no, see, it's just called learning one sentence and calling it.
Force comp.
Strongly.
Bro, you're killing me with that Spanish.
What's that?
Spanish is Te amo.
You had it right.
Italian is just really...
Is there any other ones that we haven't said?
How to say, I love you in Polish.
I love you in Polish.
Wie bin ich?
Ich bin ein Gott.
Oh, Kohamshi, in Polish it's Kohamshi.
Kohamshi, who else?
Wait, actually, let me look at location statistics.
Analytics, audience, location.
Let's see, my most...
The Philippines, oh, hi, Philippines.
How to say, I love you in Filipino.
Is mahal kita.
Did I do it right?
Mahal kita.
And where's P in this list?
P for P in...
Wait, is Filipino not a language?
Filipino?
What?
Philippines, they would speak Filipino in the Philippines.
Am I being...
It's not in Google Translate list.
Latibia.
Am I being crazy?
Filipinos have appeared.
Oh wait, no, you guys don't speak Filipino, you speak Tagalog.
Hold on, Tagalog.
Wait, Tagalog isn't on Google Translate?
What?
Tagalog isn't on Google Translate?
I love you.
Oh, Filipino's spelt with an F in English,
but the country is spelt with a P,
so I was looking in the wrong places.
Mahal kita.
Well, I didn't use Google Translate to get that to say that, right?
Okay, mahal kita, and then Germany,
which is Ishtabedi, which is Canadian,
which is just...
I love you, could you guys speak it?
Australia, again, I love you, you see.
Brazil.
Oh my God, come to Brazil.
Why is Brazil watching me?
I'm not that interesting.
Brazil speak Portuguese.
Eu te amo.
Brazil.
What are your ancestors and say in Gaelic?
I love you in Gaelic.
Curious.
I love you.
Okay, I don't have to say on that end.
There's no freaking read.
There's no read.
There's no Google read for Irish translation.
It says Irish instead of Gaelic as well,
which is curious.
You need to catch up with the lore about Scotland
and Gaelic in Ireland at the same time, right?
Brainwash me.
Oh yeah, the country is Ph for everything else's F.
Literally, I just got trolled so hard.
Cute Portuguese, Ronnie.
Placota Le Bey?
I think Placota Le Bey means hello in Portuguese.
Even Google can't pronounce Gaelic.
Literally, I typed in Gaelic and it goes Irish
and then it doesn't even a nun see anything.
Chong, baby.
Who else?
What other countries watch?
Sweden.
Who the fuck is watching from Sweden right now?
Oh my god.
What's the meaning of this?
To say Javla, fita ora.
And Sweden is for Sweden.
I said, oh wait, there's a Scottish Gaelic.
And again, it doesn't do it.
Anyway, Sweden is where it is.
Yeah, I love you.
I love you.
Scottish Gaelic is there.
Yes, but it doesn't say it out loud, so I can't mimic.
Then it goes Poland, which is Khoamshu.
And then it's France, which is Vietnam.
And then it's the Netherlands, which is the Carvagnol.
And then it's Spain, which is Te Amo.
And then there's just Finland.
Let's try Finland, but a cheeky finish.
F is for finish, let's do stuff together.
U is for unbelievably good unity.
What? Finland, F.
A, B, C, D, E.
A, B, C, D, E, F.
Oh, it was right under.
Excuse me.
I love you.
I love you for the one finish.
Irish is Bruno's Gaelic, but it's called his Gaelic.
You're getting your card revolt right now.
No, I was always Gaelic in school.
Short on behaviour.
Actually, I'm Irish then, and I find that offensive.
Wait, I just went Aussie by accident.
I can't even do an Aussie accent naturally.
Bro, sorry, it's Gaelic, sorry, Gaelic.
Also, I broke the bad news to Sin that we have to do her collab in July.
Where the heck is Russian?
I love you.
That's so fast.
Holy shit.
Can you give me like a second in between those two other sentences?
Okay, hold on.
We're going to put a comma in between love and you because it goes so fast.
Okay, you didn't change a thing.
Now your card is revoked.
I always knew you were a fake Scottish.
Sin, you can't expose me like this.
I'll jam a toothpick up your nose.
Oh wait, not a toothpick.
I actually don't, you missed it.
I accidentally jammed my freaking Japanese ear cleaner up my nose by accident
because I was swishing it about like a wand and then ended up having a
fucking laugh in my ass off over it.
Like it's tickling your ear.
You have to be Olympia.
I'm tall but I could do it.
Would you still let me far as Irish?
Here, father, who aren't in heaven?
How do I debate that name?
Someone says Icelandic.
Icelandic.
All right, there's nothing called Icelandic.
Are you trolling me right now?
I have been successfully trolling.
A longer wait for two Sculpe Grammels a year or so?
I don't know.
I love in Scottish pronunciation.
Oh my god, also go RuneScape mention.
Can you say kom in what's Cantonese?
Wait, Cantonese isn't listed.
It says Chinese simplified but is that just a massive oversight?
Yeah, it just doesn't have Cantonese.
Wow, the best you're getting is Chinese simplified from me.
How do you say it in Kotfisch?
Blah blah blah blah blah blah.
Wait, blah blah blah blah.
How fast can I do that?
Blah blah blah blah blah blah.
Now imagine that on the brineulum.
Thank you, I'll be here all week.
Please like and subscribe if you enjoyed this stream, which is not ASMR.
I'm going to start putting not ASMR at the start of ASMR streams.
Yeah, I think it would probably just be bubbles because we're under the water.
I love you.
my shoulder is just cracked
sorry I forgot to start whispering again
why me?
but yeah
pssst
raku ta saki an stroni
o a mas poste de vida
you listen with your nose
it was a mistake
I will know
I will be the ravelling that teaches a Scottish streamer
I speak gaelic
sorry
gaelic
we're gaelic over here
since sense about to rip my hair off
oh the bing-chin-ing me
bing-chin-ing
tang-jo-ma
a bing-chin-ing
the wang
you don't know the names of your bars
I'll teach ya
so you know that's super sensitive
but
it feels almost too good to be true
almost that 8k
oh please let it
actually I'm gonna
I have an edit video I can upload
now this one will get limited ads
but it's well deserved
have you been here?
sorry it means I love you too
and finish like
it's gonna be me
I'm uploading an ASMR video
and it's called
ASMR collabing
with new hands
it's gonna be quite an experience
when you click on it
that's all I'm gonna say
because my other video isn't limited
like there's literally not one video that's limited
ads on my channel so I'm not sweating
you mentioned earlier that you don't mean
bend it forward do you?
no he's like bending backwards
to like take a big sniff
guys when they learn what the
the pendulum is
like if you don't know what a pendulum is
don't worry
I'll teach ya the premium pass
for the meeting
okay
and he's stop
that's terrible
someone say me
a marshmallow
actually I should check out marshmallow
someone sent me a marshmallow
and they were like
if I was ever in front of you
I don't even think I could make eye contact
and I'm like mate
I'm so small
I'm literally like
fall in love
five two
you do not have to be intimidated by me
I'm not gonna do anything to you
oh
holy crap your whispering voice is so
oh yeah
you like it when you can hear my accent
you're so sweet to me
refling you really are
I wonder what triggers
your neurons while listening
that sound a bit more dominant
when I give a heavy whisper
is that
you're just such a subby little refling
you can't help
but mail
when I'm right up close and personal
in your ears huh
I like when you're submissive
it's cute
you're cute
I wouldn't be intimidated by you
I'd be intimidated by my own anxiety
let me hold it was an experience
well
wait until the next day
some more experience
eye contact
would you be brave enough
to look into my eyes
how are you
oh no my internet is losing the fight again
5-2 can't make eye contact
if you're that low
literally I'm like pretty sure
like almost always at all to me
although it would be really nice
if a few of you were smaller than me
then I could just absolutely annihilate you
and you'd be so kind to me
and I'd be so nice to you
kiss my ear canal
no
a melon for your fruit
I haven't ever wrote before stream
I had an old secret audio in bed
but it went everywhere
and I thought you'd know how
I haven't even done the main break stuff yet
I
wait what
I keep forgetting to record the audio
year's day 3 of 7
it's a little embarrassing at first
but now it feels natural
stroney the allegations stroney
and he sent me to fail
oops
I definitely can't be opening that
stroney ear breathing is just like
they like feeling my breath
against your ear
you've always been nice though
so I don't think you've ever not been nice
but how do you be mean
I don't know how you be mean
like unless you're
you're like genuinely want me to like
help you or something
how tall are you
I'm a hundred and like
sixty two centimeters kind of
wanna get there
I'm not very tall
you wanna kiss on the forehead
goodnight
I apologize if I said this to you
ah don't worry
um
stroney I've been watching VTubers
for four years now
wah veteran
watching VTubers big and small
successful and just starting
I've laughed
I've loved
I've cheered and I've cried
I thought I'd seen everything
the VTubers space have to offer
but the past two weeks have
driven me wrong
wait wow
I don't know what it is
or how it happened
or what the difference is
but
oops sorry
but I know this
even though I just met you
I would follow you into the dicks of
hell
your natural leadership
and magnetic personality has
built me and trapped me against you
and I wouldn't have it any other way
as also
as I kneel before you
I ask stroney
would you be my kamioshi
no you can't give me that
I've had to follow you
and all the feeler girls
for as long as this rate lasts
you can't meet me kamioshi
you can't do that
oh veteran VTubers
watch her
that's so much
that's insane
are you telling me all it took
was someone who can weaponize their ups
typical kamioshi
you're telling me you've never came across
someone with a perfect mix
of ADHD and autism your honor
oh
you know what it sounds like
it sounds like it's too late for ya
and my tentacles already have a grasp on ya
and you can't get home
now that you'd want to
not until
I'm fully done
mind breaking ya
I'm glad you enjoy all the feeler girls so much
though that's so nice
stroney is real and cannot be stopped
and will conquer the world
oh my god someone left a comment
on my RuneScape stream when I was doing my dinner
foil stuff
and they were like logistics actually cost a lot of money
and I'm like who do you think sets the fucking prices you eat ya
ah
I just deleted it
I was like no and you're not getting
you're not getting picture
you will accept my tinfoil
my tinfoil rents or you will accept none of me at all
the bill don't be
strun
strunrism
strunism is real
yes it is real
I just want to say I'm deeply envious
and in all of your productivity
the discipline and fuck it
the discipline
I have no discipline
and I have no focus
what I have
is weaponised autism
and I will scream that from the rooftops
I spawned in and rolled two pairs of dice
and they miraculously landed a 6x
ok
and those 6x equated to me being creative via ASMR
and collabing and organising and productivity in that sense
in real life jobs
I am not as good like this
although I really enjoyed my cafe job
so I may have been a cafe owner in another life
so please do not ever feel bad
ever feel guilty
ever feel anything negative
about not being productive in this day and age
I will put my tinfoil hat around right now
humans are not meant to be focused on the task
for more than 8 hours at a time
that is not possible
that is not the way we have been raised
we have been thrown into this new day and age
where nothing is adequate
why do you think there is currently a battle
about a 4 day work week
why do you think all these issues in society stem from
is it because mayhaps we are not designed
for what we are using our bodies and minds for
in this day and age
I don't know
anyway put the tinfoil hat away
put it away
we can come back to that conversation later
oh you said another sentence
sorry I didn't read it
also I want to fold you like origami or something
of course I missed that sentence and read it
ignore this
if it's already been dealt with
just wondering if the stream times are correct
no they are not
I have changed though
I will update the rest of my week on YouTube very shortly
yeah but yesterday the luck wasn't on our side
the box shot really made me feel conscious of your unluckiness
I use all my luck up on my daughters
and my reeflings
I now have both
I want nothing more
I ask for nothing more
other than you know the success of my daughters
but that's it
I heard humans can only work efficiently
for 45 minutes and the brain loses and projectivates
hello scrawny
I'm just a thought and a clip watcher for the girls
hi I thought watchers
thank you for watching us
we appreciate you
I can't read out what you said
thought watcher
but I have said something
so please don't worry
and please don't worry about being a silent viewer as well
you can be as loud or as quiet as you like
shout out to lurkers and everything
please don't ever feel forced to talk
it is not how it works
hi I just wanted to say you're doing an amazing job
and keep up what you're doing
wish you're doing an amazing job of thinking to me
so keep up what you're doing
not to be read on stream
stream
I'm reading in my head
love you to a little riefling
enjoy your holiday
oh no you're off on holiday
you're just going off on holiday
lurkers mentioned yes
you can lurk and be as quiet as you like
or you can be as active as you like
I don't like
hi momen
hi riefling
I noticed the scrawny tingle
what was a little hard to make up
in the youtube resolution
oh no
I made it the same way
maybe I can revise it and give it a shot
ehhh
pardon me
okay I'm gonna take a hydration check
everyone please hydrate
man of four hour work week
working numbers
bra honestly
everyone's like
I used to work
eight hours a week
my guy that's called you're being exploited
you're being exploited
don't feel
don't feel proud of working eight hours
you're being exploited
get out of your head
no let me in deeper
let me in your head
let my accent consume you
let my mannerisms consume you
let my personality
become you
okay
hello
hi scrawny hi riefling
I hope you're doing well
I'm doing fantastic
I have the laughing fit
and I'm high on being killers
I was wondering if you had any advice
on interacting properly
with content creators
I never know if I'm doing enough to support
or too much to support
or if I'm being parasocial or worse
I have no idea what a tribute is
and I always worry
I'm using the term oh she wrong
please don't write
I reply to tweets too often
probably
I'm probably just being anxious about nothing
I will tell you a very big advice right now
the only person
that judges you as harshly as you
is no one
they do not exist
you look at yourself
via a magnifying glass
you overthink
on things
that no one will ever think about
okay
so if you
what my wampam advice is
you are welcome to talk in my stream at any time
if you worry about
talking too much or too little
don't worry
we have the autism
me and the reflins okay
we all have issues okay
so please don't worry about socializing with us
as for in general
if you genuinely want a strategic
structured flow
I would say send a message
every 5 minutes
if the chat is slow
every 3 minutes
if the chat is fast
and try to relay your messages
to something related to the streamer
this applies to other streamers
me
you can
if we're doing an ASMR stream
you can literally say please say the sentence
and it's the most diabolical thing
written to man
that is socially acceptable
in my streams
when it comes to other streamers
try your best to stay on topic
so for example
if emi is playing the game
the coffin of andi and lele
you type
I'm so glad
I'm emi's brother
smile
that's acceptable
it's related to the game
it's related to emi's lore
perfectly fine
no problems
now you've said I'm worried about being parasocial
I always say the statement
you are welcome to be as close
or as far away as you like
as long as you are safe
and you're not showing up to people's houses
I think it's fine
but there's a lot behind this
you know parasocialism
but as long as you're safe
and you're not doing emotional damage
to yourself or others
all good to go
em a bit but
is something you might not know about
because it is related to alternative streamers
a bit but is when a wreathling
may have thoroughly enjoyed an audio
or myself in general
or a teasing
and they would like to prove to me
that they enjoyed it by sending
an audio
or a video of evidence
of enjoying it
which we have connamed inking
now for me
I am comfortable with it
because I like corrupting
and I'm fine with it
but you can always put it in
you can just drop it in my marshmallow
I have got a little folder going
I've got an audio folder
and a video folder
you are worried about using oshi
so oshi means
well actually the wreathlings
might be able to describe this better than I ever can
can oshi mean someone
that you enjoy watching
and you are there
like they're your best streamer
in a roster
like if you had to do a 1v1 lineup
they kept coming out on top
yeah
you're worried about your reply to tweets too often
and you're worried about being anxious over nothing
I think you might be a little in your own head
which is okay
everyone is
don't think you're the only person to ever have these issues
to ever come to the man
to ever do this to ever do that
if you're worried about replying to tweets too often
my question for you
do you reply to every single tweet?
I think liking a tweet
every single tweet
perfectly fine
replying to every tweet
if it is causing you emotional distress
with the anxiety
then I think
reply every 3 tweets
is more than socially acceptable
or on tweets that you feel ever so inclined to reply on
so for example
if your oshi posts
her weekly schedule
I think it's more than acceptable to say
I'm really looking forward
to this stream on this day
okay
oh here we go
refling comes in
oshi is used for idols and celebrities
who you like it means
I like and support
I would oshi originates from the kanji
recommendation
okay
yes
so please just remember
your head the most
eh
and
yes
someone says you said before you're not into the idea of being
okay I don't think I could say that in this stream
we'll say it in transformers
okay
stream warning please don't say this out loud
what happens if I do say it out loud huh
are you gonna bust
stroney I'm glad you're Scottish
because when you say ours is making me want to disable your abilities
that's bloody creative
I'll give you that
that's creative
wait she's actually dropping stream of urges right
I don't want anyone ever feeling like their
you know
and the
doing their thing
like I just want you to enjoy yourself
and if you're overthinking it
then we're gonna tackle that together
hi stroney I love your laugh
also your voice is my new favorite ASMR trigger
oh yeah you like my croaky voice
you like grailock the kind from Skyrim
I bet that refling found that very helpful
oh I hope so
just being curious
is acceptable if someone comments on every tweet
or is that wrong
I think it's perfectly fine
but I don't tweet all the time
so yeah
if you maybe watch a streamer
that is addicted to tweeting
I don't know
I don't know what their comfort levels would be
I don't, it does not bother me none
I am rubbish on Twitter
please don't ever feel bad
if I don't like give you a like on Twitter or something
and my tags aren't working
I can never see my freaking tags
ah
pachinko thank you for the 5 gifted
congrats on who caught it with her face
congrats
okay
stroney I've never liked
watching Vtuber streams
but yours are the most enjoyable
oh
sorry I'm so sorry
if you heard that
sorry
please
sashimi thank you for becoming a member
I'm so sorry if you heard that
bonk
was it stroney
I've never liked watching Vtuber
but yours are the most enjoyable streams
I've ever watched you're doing great
keep up lovely couple fish thank ya
te amo te amo mi amores
another gen 2
recommendation okay
okay I'll hear you out
gen 2 anonymous recommendation
a clumsy
curious curious
athletic fitness
3 freak
curious
a cheerleader pimple
ah can we get candy roll for gen 2
can I just hire their voice actor
crazy scientist
hippie potted
like hypopotamus
and then an emo
called the rock star
okay curious
curious
interesting interesting
wait someone sent me a poem
what the heck you guys are so good at poems
everything you do
it sends me higher than the moon
with every twinkle in your eye
you strike a match
that lights my heart on fire
when you're near
I hate my blushing face
and trip on my shoelaces
grace just isn't my forte
but it brings me to my knees
when you say hello
how are you my darling
today I fall into
a pail on the floor
but we love is hard to ignore
when every little thing you do
I do adore oh my god that's so great
what the heck you guys
didn't tell me you studied Shakespeare
someone says just reply
when you can add something
oh that's so cute
I think your meme tag
is spelled incorrectly
no no no no no
so originally it was going to be
cephalobok
but then I spelled it wrong
with cephalobok
and then I realized
that's exactly on par for me
so I leave it as cephalobok
I've been watching Vtuber since
and you're the only person I've been willing to get
up at 3am
bro I thought I was bad
waking up at 4am
bruh
sorry Ozzy
I apologize
I'm 5'3
but I'm willing to list the kneecaps
for you I'm not gonna lie
nah you're perfect
for sitting on
because I can get you to lie down
on the floor
and
and if you're 5'3
that means I'm at crochet
okay I had to tint my tentacle a few times
during this
multiple
refractionary
itching
why?
I strongly as a scout listening
to you put that English accent on
I heard you're so
what's wrong with having a chat yet
who do you mean an overwatch
I don't play overwatch anymore
I'm so sorry
I'm sorry a little too briefly
I used to play Saria
strong as a mountain
and Reinhard
Reinhard Reinhard Reinhard
hi hey strongy
I'm falling during
us security
at this convention
I need to get back in shape for the event
can I get some motivation
for the gym please
how are you supposed to breathe
if you can't lift me every time
I sit on your face
now lift me
or go home
now
is that the motivation you need
I'm watching you during a workout
risking the
oh during work
risking the job just for you
let's see just wanted to say
I've been loving your streams
and the vids you upload especially the ASMR
attend not to comment and stop because I'm kind of
conscious of all this sort of stuff
but don't send a supportive message
to tell you keep up much love
much love refling
don't worry if you're shy it's perfectly okay
I know you're there I can see likes
on my videos
I know you're leaving likes
because you're so good to me
hi strongy I love your laugh
did you like when I couldn't stop laughing
because I shoved an ear cleaner up my nose
why would I want to breathe anything
else after breathing you in
just have incredible lung strength
yeah I think that's probably
pretty perfect
yeah that guy's gonna be ripped
why would I lift you though
because you're not supposed to perish
from sitting
you're supposed to be able to push me off
and throw me around
bend me
there that's all the motivation
for the gym bros
now for my architects however
you keep eating that takeaway
and for my beanballs
don't worry all the better
to throw you around
I remember
when you guys taught me
of beanball men
and it's a body type of beanball
for skinny malinky guys
oh yes chat struggling
man
what did I walk into
a freaking ASMR nightmare
thoughts on stoners
I don't have any thoughts
unfortunately
I've never partaken
in such a thing before
but as long as you're happy
I'm happy that's the main thing
to be careful of your lungs
however because you may
have been fed
a cheeky lie that
it doesn't do any damage
to your lungs but that's wrong
it's smoke inhalation it does do damage
so please do look after yourself
and get yourself checked out
if you have a reoccurring cough
please do get checked out
for COPD
very not fun condition
so please do look after yourself
unironically
check out hearingstrone
almost everyday
please tell me you can come
into our members stream
I want to say really inappropriate things
for the reeflings that
do stuff like work
and are in public
and stuff
I'm not going to try and get you to
get uh
oh did you hear that
I just poked a sponge by accident
what
oh thank you for the gift dude
yeah thank you for the gift
left for the pen
what's the word for mario body
type if you're built like a short
jack scale isn't that just
a beanpole
all the better to nominate
you if you can
if you've been here
okay
I am going to have to go
because I need to
set up for a membership stream
so we're going to redirect into someone
who I have no idea
I'm going to see if any of the yumi plus girls
are on if they're not
then it's going to vnu
because I need to return the favor to vnu
and I'm yet to do that
I am going to do a membership
strum
no one is live
oh my god there has to be
a freaking
that can't be right
hold on is there a yumi plus that's about to go live
oh my god
I'm farting
internally sorry I'm not going to
fart on the mic I apologize for anyone
I go excited there what time is it
6am is anyone streaming
who's got
is there a vnu right who's live a vnu
v and you
I don't care who's live you're getting
oh there must be one vnu girl from jinn
freaking
AAA club is
wait is serenity on
because serenity always reads into me
serenity
why aren't you online
right maybe
are you online
why aren't you online
don't moy me
wait vnu
get online
I want to
why is there no vnu
online
okay we're going to go to
miss mia because you actually watched us
are you live
what the fuck
why is no one a vnu
I'm literally in a second generation
spectra
are you online no
Sally are you online
Sally what the fuck
hello vnu
vnu are you all in an idol meeting
okay we're going to go to oracle
in vnu
looking for any oracle member vnu
to be online
question mark
vnu hello
offline
seri is offline
maith
maith is offline
hold on a minute I'm not even meming
not one vnu girl is online
saion is doing fucking
maincraft mv
maincraft but it's a collab
and I can't read into it out of respect
for the collab members
vnu hold vnu
what timezone do you all stream at
I'm not even meming vnu
and there's not one live yumi plus member
is obi online
I spoke to obi and she was nice to me
oh wait oban sorry oban
what
I can't click
oban are you online
oh
oban vtuber
according to holodex not one vnu
wait oban
her name's not oban
what I spoke to her yesterday
of course her name's fucking oban
the vtuber why is it when I type in oban vtuber
it doesn't come off
I'm getting hate crying right now for being Scottish
I don't know
sorry I didn't even
sorry let me just turn down the fucking volume
there's not one vnu girl
I'm not even online right now
vnu girls just so you hate me
wait
where is oban
not online either
not one yumi plus
not one vnu
right who do you just want me to read then
I swear it's oban
is it obami
and I'm spelling her name wrong
is that true
there's not one vtuber on youtube
right now that I can read into
wait
fucking mythoshq don't even stream
on youtube
did they mythoshq
those girls are legit they're nice
none of them
what the fuck
wait
so wait there's really not a yumi plus girl
that's live right now
who should I read into
you know what
vtuber ASMR live stream
show me right now who's live right now
don't ASMR
a Japanese girl
these are just fallen shadow replay videos
this is vividly ASMR replay
video
her course
did an offline collab
with the owl 11 days ago
which I actually didn't know about
there's shiki
dr nova
let's check out dr nova
actually I was mean to reach out to that company
cause they actually seem pretty legit
art sports
what's she doing she's talking
let's read into her
she's talking in a dumpster
you know whatever makes her happy
oh she's happy I'm happy
can I
do the live stream
thank you
sorry that took me so long
I'll be up in the membership stream
okay
please be very nice to dr nova
of
um
dr nova
of
v for
mirai
um
I
don't know what their temperament is
please understand I tolerate
a lot of things that a lot of vtubers don't
tolerate so please do be a good reflection
on the streamer of my good side
not my horny side
I will talk to you goofy goobers
very shortly in 10 minutes
if you're a membership there should be a membership stream
but thank you so so much
please be really nice and say hi to dr nova
I will talk in her chat just to not
bomb you guys in and then leave
instantly but thank you so so much for this
thank you for having me a giggle
okay I'll see you in the